they started coming in trickles
some with only the clothes on their
backs
then they arrive in numbers
in just under a week more than 4 000
refugees arrive in this small border
Village of coffron in Chad
and this is what they're coming to a
life of hardship
many say they've not eaten in 24 hours
and when help begins to arrive the
relief is huge
but for some the trauma remains
three people were killed and nine
injured in an ambition are Convoy when
we tried to flee two cars were destroyed
this family shares the little supplies
they receive
it may not be enough
but it will do for a day or two
most of the Sudanese refugees live under
matchive structures like these eight
agencies say there are hundreds of
Sudanese refugees within the community
or are yet to be registered and
therefore cannot access Aid these
numbers are expected to increase in the
coming days and weeks
eight agencies are worried that if the
influx of refugees continues there
wouldn't be much left to give
the local authorities here are
overwhelmed by the numbers
the presence of more than four thousand
refugees is beginning to affect the
local economy
right now the cost of food has gone up
by 70 percent in our markets governments
along with its partners are
collaborating to ease the situation for
our population
generals continue to shoot and bomb each
other The Exodus Will Go On
the United Nations estimates that more
than a quarter of a million people will
cross into child alone in the coming
weeks and months
this will increase the suit in his
Refugee population here to more than 750
000 and with Aid agencies low on funds
and relieve materials the condition of
these refugees can only get worse